[Music]
[Music]
what interests me in biotech is it's the
future it's really transforming medicine
how it has bio ethical implications and
just like longevity changing society I
mean there's so much to think about I'm
personally really excited for all the AG
friends oncologist therapeutics are
booming so I think that's awesome
learn about nd bio through their
synthetic biology investments
aquaculture related companies converting
co2 into fish feed which is really
important to me as an ocean guy
I'm really excited to see how biotech is
changing ocean sustainability create an
alternative to the forage fish that
we're grinding up and feeding to all the
aquaculture fish that we eat my passion
for me and it's really cool to see it I
think a new bio is helping inspire a lot
of the effort in the past I was very
interested in like gene therapy
synthetic biology now I'm less
interested in technical I'm more
interested in collaboration between
private and public taking a part of the
pharmaceutical industry or the biotech
company and really finding where does
strategic collaboration can happen with
academia having both worked in both area
I find that there is absolute synergy
that can be created but we need
translators between academia and really
startup world
[Music]
but anybody else one of the best demo
days of the year has been going for many
years and I've been coming the whole
time there's a whole spectrum of
different kinds of companies from food
and medical and I like treating DNA as
software and being able to program in
DNA and you can do all kinds of things
once you have that working both the
tools and the applications are
interesting to me but is there one that
you're really keeping an eye on and why
absolutely it's genetic engineering
correct a lot of point mutations we can
do things like reprogramming our immune
systems you're also getting into things
like enhancements the idea of designer
babies that's really interesting to me
philosophically and ethically where do
you cross the line
yeah I hope we can have a global
conversation to make sure that everyone
can be as ethically grounded as possible
because I first see a lot of
geopolitical pressures
[Music]